this is actually a serious point right
this is a very serious point because the
Western world has collapsed in real time
and it's a failed society and one of the
reasons is a failed Society is because
of the over-sexualization especially of
females as a whole if a woman comes up
to me and goes I'll be the best sex you
ever had I am [__] revolted I don't
want the best sex I've ever had I want
you to be pure and a virgin you should
know what sex is cook my [__] dinner
shut up don't come and talk to me about
[__] sucking dick it's vile it's
disgusting I don't want to hear that
[__] can I say something I don't want to
hear that [__] what I want is a woman
that makes me look good no woman who's
running around talking about sucking
dick can make me look good so I lose
interest completely and utterly and
that's the truth so what she's saying is
completely correct these are old school
things but it's not about the ACT yes
you can order food of course it's about
the status that comes with it that's
what it's about uh Sagittarius spoken
like a true one that is true
well my man so basically it's a straight
shooting sort of conversation but I
think that sometimes we get distracted
and we talk about the bigger because
between men and women I think that the
problem that men and women have is the
consequences of the bad decisions that
the one percent of powerful men make on
our behalf because our problems are on a
societal level less than between woman
and man that is why there's a lot of
competition between men this trace for
status that they will never get men why
is that the fault of the one percent of
men because they're the ones that drive
the machine that runs this the Western
it's always been that way yeah and but
then think about the men that at the top
now the corruption and everything that's
going on and this is why it feels very
good to sit next to somebody like you
and just say you know what I appreciate
that you say things that are really true
you expose a very toxic truth and a very
true truth as well that is out there but
the reality is on the trenches when you
go to the Grassroots people don't feel
the way that you feel it's not as simple
as what you say they are victims of this
system so my job here is really not to
try and make about men and women is to
make you understand that actually we
need to start changing the narrative we
want to make it about men and women
because they're both messed up on either
side because then women look bad no
because it's about everybody together
women have their traumas men have their
traumas I'm not here to fight against
men and women that's small I understand
what you're saying I understand what
you're saying but the idea the idea the
idea that this is one percent of men
have created this terrible Society yeah
I talk about that I talk about the
Matrix I talk about these things but
it's always been this way it's always
been a small Elite group of men who are
in charge of the world and unfortunately
now we're fighting battles in different
ways the the days of old a man proved
his worth by going to war basically
every man at any point in his life was
going to end up going to war and he came
back Victorious he came back with honor
he got himself a wife that's that's how
it worked right now men don't have to go
to war as much depending on where you
live in the world and it's slightly
different and we fight our Wars in other
ways and one of the true expressions of
testosterone and trying to really
express your ability and your combative
ability now in the in the modern world
is power and influence so in the olden
days you'd go to war you come back with
a ribbon nowadays you've got x amount of
followers you can move the world with
money I can bend reality with money
please understand if I walk into Jimmy
Choo they lock the door no broke he's
allowed in Tates here and I bought what
the [__] I want there's lines outside
because I'm there I bend the world with
money that's how I that's how the wars
are now won so you're talking about high
status males and then it's always been
that way now you have a whole contingent
of men who aren't dead okay they didn't
die in a ditch but they're loneliest
[__] jerking off and that's the reality
of it and and women don't give a [__]
about them and why should you I'm not
sitting here actually [__] on women
in any way I think women have a
biological instinct to a degree to try
and find the best mate they can because
it gives them the highest chance of
survival and the harsh realities of the
world and if they look at a man who's
not capable they just don't feel an
attraction to him and that's the bottom
line of it and that's why I actually
most I'm largely misunderstood I don't
blame women for a lot of the problems
women are guilty of certain things but I
have a massive amount of blame to place
on men because there's so many men who
are genuinely incompetent I was a chick
I wouldn't [__] these losers either like
they're losers so it's hard to balance I
love it you know what I understand why
people always go after one percent all
the women one was for the one percent
why don't you just find a regular
nine-to-five person enough after you you
can be his Queen why can't you just do
that why is everybody really rushing
I've got a man we don't go on social
media if it went for a part of not about
social media nine to five I got around
property 32 years happy as Larry what is
the problem it's not old-fashioned it
can it works no Auntie let me clarify
when I meant one percent is not the one
percent of Attraction I mean the actual
people that are in charge of the things
that run the world the way that what I'm
trying to say is that it's always been
an umbrella we've lived under but a
different functioned underneath it so
why is it going to affect me I'll
explain why because as Sir Mr Andrew
King Tate said
I'll have this one after this boys
it is I've been drinking lime juice as
well so as he very rightly said Society
has now evolved before men went to war
now men don't go to war so there's a lot
of sense of no purpose that they need to
find and then on the women's side is
that the same way that a society evolved
and made men feel less purpose they have
now had to to take on bigger purposes
they have to go to work like they didn't
have to do before they have to take care
of the family and work and do all of
these things and now deal with the fact
that men are feeling a little bit like
out of you know the rubbish say what I'm
saying you're getting nine to five
person right what is wrong with you
going out there find a regular nine to
five person right you can function
underneath that because I'm always
saying the women say oh we ain't got
enough money we ain't got enough money
work with what the man's got you're
right work with what the man's got you
can make a manual Alpha everybody wants
to go and find these top earning money
find a nine to five work regular save
your money learn to cook and not have
takeouts and then save your money as
they did before then you should direct
this to the men that feel upset because
they're not like Angels
she's completely completely right I'll
give you I'll tell you this there's not
a girl on this panel or on the planet
today who couldn't walk outside and find
a man who's gonna be nice to her loyal
to her and make her his Queen women
don't want that so they'll sit there and
go no I want Chris Brown and then
they'll go try and get Chris Brown then
Chris Brown will cheat and they'll be
like I can't believe he cheated I am
devastated well what the [__] do you
think is gonna happen if I go to the car
garage right you have to make a decision
what you truly want in your life if you
truly want to just find a manager and
look after you and take care of you
you're gonna be his Queen he's going to
be loyal you can find that all day but
you're going to have to settle to a
degree where a lot of women perhaps are
not prepared to do that you see the you
see how women act they'd rather chase a
fraction of a real G's time than have a
hundred percent of the time of a [__]
dude who they don't they don't respect
at that level and it's kind of like
going to a car dealership you walk in
there you if you want reliability you
can get a Nissan but if you want to get
a Ferrari it comes with it comes with
headaches it's going to come with
problems so when girls say to me oh you
know what Andrew you know you should be
loyal to men like me don't have to be
and you know that so why the [__] are
you [__] are you trying to tell me what
to do because you know I don't have to
be loyal and all the girls I'm [__]
don't have to be loyal so why are you
sitting there pretending you expected me
to be loyal when everyone knew from
ground up day one it was never going to
ever [__] happen and you're still
here I think you're still texting
they're gonna be the one that changes
that's the biggest mistake you think
ghosts make this is the female decision
they sit there and decide no I want this
this this this this cool then you're
gonna have to accept it ain't gonna be
loyal to you he's barely gonna reply to
you that's the game they liked me and
cheated I swear to God this show has
made me believe I think women like to be
cheated on I don't I swear to God no
because all you'll ever talk about is
your exes that cheated on you that's all
you'll ever talk about and it's like
it's like I always talks about that the
regular women are running the women oh
good thing I'm irregular and
extraordinaire but do you not think it's
because we're not holding meant
accountable so when I'm mad because he's
a top J cheats on a woman it's like well
what do you expect when you should
actually turn around
accountable okay accountable for its
natural evolutionary biology is cheating
morally correct yes it depends yes
how can you say that are you okay with
your woman cheating on you then
absolutely not that's all no because oh
it's a rap when she from you but you can
cheat on her there has not been in the
history of humanity across any culture
any book any story any Fable there has
never been across the history of
humanity any respect put on the name of
a promiscuous female ever ever you name
the biggest conquerors that you can
possibly name from history Genghis Khan
Alexander the Great all of them they all
had 100 wives bunch of children Big G
conquered the world normal that is
normal evolutionary biology that's how
men are designed to be there's never
been a single female who's been
celebrated for a promiscui ever in
history it's always been frowned upon
and disgusting so yes we are completely
and utterly different yes it's different
if a woman cheats on a man and if a man
is at a complete top level of his life
and ticks every single box and if he
decides to be loyal which some do and I
can be loyal and I have been loyal but
there's also times in my life where I
think [__] it I don't want to be and get
a new girlfriend every single day of the
week I can do that and I can decide to
do that if a woman decides to do the
same purely because her value is high
enough to attract so many males because
she's beautiful for example it is
completely different and I'm gonna
explain to you why it's completely
different so buckle up it's different
it's different it's different well I'll
tell you why because it's impossible for
a female to be promiscuous on a long
enough period of time without devaluing
herself because she is [__] people
she shouldn't be [__] there is no way
she is sleeping with endless men and all
of them are either high value men or
treating her the way she should be
treated if you find a woman who slept
with 50 100 dudes she's either [__]
dudes which are at her level or haven't
worked hard enough to try and get the
[__] Shooters too drunk to realize he's
a loser who plays video games or she's
[__] a top G who barely texts her
back so either way she's [__] dude
she shouldn't be [__] or a guy who's
at the level who doesn't give her the
right amount of attention for a woman to
find a guy who's truly on a level who
truly treats her the way she should be
treated that's once every couple years
if that you ain't just gonna go out
there [__] a new dude every week and
say yeah he's worth [__] yeah he treats
me good enough to get my [__] and you
know what's funny about the universe
it's actually beautiful about the
universe because it's equal and opposite
forces when you devalue yourself it's
kind of like men can smell it on you
they can just look at a [__] and go oh
and that's the way it works so you have
to be very careful as a female and sit
and go does this man truly deserve to
[__] me if you think about it the answer
99 of the time especially if you're
promiscuous is no so when a woman is
sleeping around with all these men she's
devaluering herself she's devaluing
herself and the world knows God knows
the universe knows when a man does it he
doesn't devalue himself at all that's
just the way it works can I ask you a
question wait wait wait so one second
sir may I ask you a question what would
you say if a woman now is married to two
men
no I'll tell you why let's talk about
this what is the difference between a
man let's say me I have four wives right
what's the difference between a man
having four wives and a woman having
four men you can impregnate the four
wives at the same time you're gonna
pregnant the four wives at the same time
and we know who the parents are right so
let's say you had four pregnancies you'd
know who the mother is because she's
carrying the baby and you know who the
dad is top G if you had a woman with
four men and she gets pregnant who's
supposed to parents what about if but no
but I'm asking okay I ask what if
they're different races
you don't know the question you don't
know now modern science can come along
and maybe fix that for you but that
doesn't mean it's not wrong in the eyes
of God the idea of having a family the
idea of a child being born one of the
baselines for a new life to come onto
this planet is for at least to
understand who the two people who made
it are at least if you have a woman
[__] four Dudes you don't even know
who's who who are pregnant so may I just
disgusted wait wait have you seen the
twins that had two different dads oh
yeah I saw that may I just say something
then so if that is the case yeah if the
one thing that you meant Hobbies you at
least you know who the two people that
put that child on Earth are then that's
why promiscuity for men is also a
problem because they get women pregnant
sometimes they don't even know they have
children that's around no no it's
completely different it's different
because you have to understand I'm
talking about humans you look at humans
from a societal perspective but Society
has changed right so let's say two three
hundred years ago if a woman got
pregnant she needed a man to survive if
that man didn't take care of her during
pregnancy she was going to die she
couldn't work a job she couldn't hunt
couldn't fish whatever right a woman
literally needed that man for survival
so if if you were to come to me and say
I'm pregnant but you've been [__] by
four different dudes probably like who
says it's mine why am I looking after
you none of them want to look after her
she will literally perish this is why in
most of the world today still today
Virginia is so coveted and throughout
all of history it's been so coveted
because that's the only way to ensure
paternity she's a virgin I know that's
my baby she a virgin prove it's mine
outside of this modern science [__]
shaitan the devil we have here in the
west and most of the world today without
virginity or at least a low body count
or at least uh anti-promiscuity you
can't tell that that's your baby so it's
a completely different thing you're
looking at the idea of a man a woman
being pregnant and coming to a group of
men and saying one of you has to take
care of me and put up with me when I'm
fat and Moody and annoying and I need my
bills paid and all the men are going to
sit there and go no [__] no prove it's
mine you can't prove it bounce where
it's different if I get four women
pregnant we know that we know the deal
okay so let me ask you a question so
obviously back then for survival women
needed a man otherwise when they were
pregnant could die and all of these
things they would perish in today's
society given Evolution given the fact
that as women we can go to school yeah
but I'm I'm not saying that isn't there
a glitch between what is actually
happening and the nature of what we have
in our bodies I think that's probably
the conflict that we're having right now
glitch in what way in the sense that
women don't feel like they need men in
the most physical sense perhaps like
naturally it's very interesting women
don't feel like they need men in a
physical sense because life is soft but
it's but it's but it's [__] and it's
[__] because you still need Men by
proxy one and two the second life gets
difficult you very quickly you very
quickly learn how much you need men but
women don't go I'm independent I don't
need no man because I have an only fans
and Men be my only fans and if anyone
comes up to me I'll call a male police
officer I don't need men shut up [__]
idiot of course you do you just named
your whole life it's based on [__]
men the roads are driving along was
paved by a man the house you're living
in was built by a man the car you're
driving who was designed by a man your
whole life depends on men and the second
anything bad were to happen to you the
second you were physically threatened or
times were to get hard or War were to
start or famine or riots the first thing
you do is find a big strong man [__]
yourself and throw the feminism out the
window feminism goes out the [__]
window the second that the snow needs
shoveling or there's a [__] broken
down car or the tire needs changing then
all that crap vanishes it's garbage and
this is the actual very interesting
thing I'll make a point here which is
gonna be canceled again but I don't give
a [__] but this is the point feminism in
and of itself can't be defended any idea
the point of an idea is that can be
defended by the people who believe in it
this is what the whole point of War
since the dawn of time it doesn't matter
if it's the Christians against the
Hindus doesn't matter if it was the
Germans against the French there were
people who had ideas and ideology season
they're prepared to fight each other to
defend their ideology feminism is an
ideology which cannot be defended by
feminists the only people who could
defend feminism are The Men Who
subscribe to the garbage with you it's
all the feminists were to get in a line
and say we want feminism and the
conservative men were to get a line you
would learn very quickly it's [__] I
had a friend in Afghanistan when Taliban
kicked America out and he told me
the Americans were telling were telling
the girls they could go to school so
they built all these girls schools and
they put the afghanistani Defense Forces
there and they'd get funded the
Afghanistan forces to to protect these
schools you had American satellites you
had night vision goggles Taliban were
afraid to attack America leaves now you
have Afghani Defense Forces they're
basically blind they don't have
satellites anymore don't have a night
vision whatever so now it's a real war
the men are standing next to this girl's
school the Taliban are coming you're
some dude you're standing there and
you're looking at this girl's school
going
I don't really give a [__] if girls go
to school bounce and you just and you
didn't fight so that's why they all gave
up and Taliban took over so quickly and
when I said this the girls like yeah
they should have fought for us feminism
to why don't the women fight can I ask
oh wait the women can't defend their own
[__] idea you need men to defend
feminism so that's why the whole thing
is stupid so second men don't defend it
it does it just fails it's a [__]
ideology it's garbage may I tell you
something now so this is the thing this
is when we assume that women perhaps
don't have the physical or even mental
ability to go to school wait wait
because this is the thing for example in
Ukraine a lot of women took up arms and
in fact I'm angolan wait wait I'm
angolan wait wait I'm angolan listen to
people at home wait no worries I'll talk
about myself
wait let me tell you let me tell you
something this is the thing I think it's
also really like silly to assume that
for example woman because she didn't go
to school she'll not be as intelligent
as a man therefore naturally a woman is
not intelligent no it doesn't make sense
if we're not starting to normalize
equality and we want to put everybody in
the Forefront give a woman a normalizing
equality well that's what what people
are wanting then that's okay let me tell
you I want to normalize the quality
people like oh feminists well actually
no equality I want respect that's videos
from getting respects no I get respect
I get respected
what I think is you never know what you
want I'll tell you what I don't know
what you want you're right as a woman I
carry myself differently I actually hold
the things I have done in the fight side
for I hold it that's why when you speak
to me I don't move different I move
different to many of the girls that's
why when you talk to me and you argue
with me I don't take it you do something
and I'll tell you something a lot of
women may have the accolades to be
somebody but they are uncomfortable to
own that and the reason why then I would
like to ask you for example
um I do need a man for example to you
know procreate but other than that I'm
quite strong and I would find things
that I would find a way to protect
myself differently with that mentality
what would be the man that would be for
me then another what would you do if one
of these security guards broke into your
door
[Laughter]
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible